Elon Musk is once again putting his
money where our mouths are Elon has just
announced that for the first time in the
history of big Tech quote if you were
unfairly treated by your employer due to
posting or liking something on this
platform we will fund your legal bill No
Limit please let us know
the Tweet receipt or xpost or whatever
it I don't whatever they're calling it
out doesn't matter came in response to
reports that a NASCAR driver was
suspended by his League
for liking a meme that referenced George
Floyd
we'll get to that story in just a moment
elon's offer is welcome regardless of
this particular story that caused it
because Elon is proving a hugely
important point about free speech that
the right is largely missed the right
misunderstands a lot about free speech
for at least a couple decades now the
right has defended free speech in the
abstract without getting into the
nitty-gritty of substance what exactly
it is that we want to say we pretended
to be neutral and this was always
foolish because all societies have
standards and Free Speech in the
abstract means nothing to people who
have nothing to say but Elon here is
proving another important point
which is that free speech in the
abstract any kind of speech standard
really means nothing to people who have
no power to enforce it
so we bleat on and on about the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights and
the free Marketplace of ideas and then
the left censors us
and then we whine some more
and then what happens the left sensors
are some more because the libs have the
power to do it
this is why Elon is so great and
revolutionary for the right
he doesn't just pull out his pocket
Constitution and explain how you know
what Google is doing is actually very
wrong because if you look here in
paragraph three Elon puts up 44 billion
dollars and a lot more to come it would
seem to make sure that conservatives at
least have a shot at saying the true
normal things that we want to say both
in principle and in practice without
losing our livelihoods for it I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show Megan rapino
who is the soccer lady she doomed her
team the U.S women's soccer team to lose
the big game for the big thing I don't
know I've never watched a soccer game in
my life and all red blooded American
Patriots are cheering the loss of the
U.S women's team so we'll get to why
that is in just a second because it's a
little odd isn't it Patriots cheering
the loss of the US team
it's a paradox but it does make sense
we'll get into it in a second first I
want to turn to another sport NASCAR
where a guy got canceled for liking a
meme this guy is Noah gragson
he was suspended from the league
by the Legacy motor club and NASCAR
because he appeared to like a meme that
made a little bit of a joke about George
Floyd
so he's he's out
and he's already owned up to it he's
posted his public apology for the Stalin
show trial to beg forgiveness I'm
disappointed in myself he says for my
lack of attention and actions on social
media I understand the severity of this
situation I love and appreciate everyone
I try to treat everyone equally no
matter who they are I messed up plain
and simple please don't kill me it's
like it's like a North Korean prisoner
begging begging for clemency it's very
very sad and it shows you an important
distinction that a lot of the squishy
conservatives
haven't gotten
it's the distinction between
authoritarianism and totalitarianism
this word authoritarian which I think
should probably be crossed out of the
English language because the way it's
used in America doesn't mean anything
anymore but the word authoritarian
I guess it would refer to a government
like
I don't know Franco's Spain I guess
would be authoritarian today the libs
say that Hungary orban's Hungary is
authoritarian which I was just over
there it's not it's absolutely
Preposterous to call that place
authoritarian it is illiberal though so
okay what does it mean what what are the
libs meaning when they say it's
authoritarian they mean that the
government has clear standards clear
limits in certain well-defined areas of
law and Society
so let's say hey no Pride parades no
weird curricula in the schools
no
degenerate behavior on the streets
but
what you want to do in your private life
we're not going to pay much attention to
that's what they say they say look our
government our society it's not going to
be a liberal Society it's not going to
be a progressive Society it's going to
be a Christian Society Christianity is
going to animate our public life but the
government will say this openly they'll
say we're not talking about people's
individual Faith you can pursue your
individual Faith as you see fit
we're not we're not going to send in the
Purity police into your bedroom and into
your living room to enforce your
religious behaviors we're just saying as
a political matter the Christian view
the Christian morality that's what's
going to Define our culture the same
thing John Adams said at the founding of
America
totalitarian is different
totalitarian does not have very highly
defined narrow limits in which the the
government is saying okay this is going
to be our standard in totalitarian
societies
it's everything it's everything
such that if you sitting on your couch
accidentally linger too long on a meme
on your private little app on your phone
and you maybe you laugh a little too
hard at it you're going to be canceled
you're going to lose your livelihood
maybe you'll be prosecuted you'll be
ostracized you're out
big big difference
and the irony of it is that in our
liberal Western societies all the big
Libs societies of Europe and the United
States we're told this is freedom oh we
live in for you can do whatever you want
we're not like those authoritarian
societies out there in Eastern Europe
the authoritarian societies even further
east no no sir we're liberal
people are much Freer in supposedly
authoritarian regimes than they are in
the liberal West very often because the
liberal West ironically is totalitarian
now when you want to preserve a little
something for yourself especially as the
political order gets crazy you gotta
check out Birch gold right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 we are now days away
from the Durban Accords
Durban Accords could be the greatest
threat to the US Dollar's Global
dominance in the past 80 years why
should you care since the turn of the
century the world's dollar supply grew
344 percent
each Dollar's purchasing power has
declined 44 leaders around the world are
questioning the value of owning an asset
with Unlimited Supply and a steadily
declining value on August 22nd brics
Nations Brazil Russia India China and
South Africa are expected to announce
the launch of a new international super
currency fully backed by gold or other
Commodities this is part of their
long-term plan to supplant the US dollar
and it's the Cornerstone of the Global
Financial system which could lead to
dire consequences such as higher prices
on Global Imports and Rising loan rates
because the world is simply less willing
to finance mortgages and infrastructure
projects in the U.S you can protect your
IRA or 401K from The Fallout by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
historically gold has been a safe haven
in times of high uncertainty which is
right now how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings today
virtual as an A plus rating with a
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text Knowles to 98 98 98
get your free info kit on gold it'll be
nice to have some gold to depend upon
again as things collapse text nulls
kwles to 98 98 98
. speaking of debate in the free
Marketplace of ideas
Governor Gavin Newsom over there in
California Gamora by the sea has
challenged foreign Governor Ron DeSantis
to a debate
and Ron DeSantis accepts the challenge
you heard Gavin make the offer your
answer is absolutely I'm game let's get
it done just tell me when and where
we'll do it and here's the thing Sean I
mean in in one respect the um the debate
between California and Florida you know
has already been had as you suggest
people have been voting on that they've
been voting on it with their feet they
have fled California in record numbers
Florida has been the number one state
for net in migration we have the number
one ranked economy number one now in
education crime rate at a 50-year low
but in another sense this is the debate
for the future of our country because
you have people like Joe Biden they
would love to see the Californication of
the United States Biden may not even be
the nominee you could have Gavin Newsom
you could have Kamala Harris and I think
if we go down that direction that's
going to accelerate American decline we
can't see America decline anymore we
need to reverse Amer American decline
there we go here's the pitch and it's
going to be a good debate and he's right
DeSantis is totally right the debate
between Florida and California has
already been had and the way you can
tell who won the debate is which way the
U-Hauls are moving the U-Hauls are
leaving California they're going to
Florida okay so this is a great idea I I
think it would be instructive to a lot
of people to see the difference between
good government and bad government smart
policies bad policy is great
the downside of this for DeSantis is it
suggests that he is not focusing on
beating Trump for the nomination
because if he were focused on beating
Trump for the nomination he would just
be debating Trump all the time and
focusing on trying to get Trump to
debate the
the debate DeSantis and the rest of the
2024 primary field this debate between
DeSantis and Newsome feels a little bit
like the second tier debate it feels a
little bit like the Cruz versus Bernie
Sanders socialism debate that happened
just after the 2016 election which was
very instructive you've got Cruz who's
got very clearly defined political views
and you've got Sanders who's obviously
the biggest socialist in the country and
they're going to have the debate out
that's a that's a very instructive
debate but it doesn't feel like the
stakes are very high here because as of
now Joe Biden is the Democrat nominee
for president and frankly as of now
Trump is the Republican nominee for
president and and this this doesn't help
DeSantis look like he's on the cusp of
dislodging trump now
on the other hand this is smart in that
because of age and prosecutions
persecutions there is a significant
chance that Biden is not the Democrat
nominee and the Trump is not the
Republican nominee so in that case there
will be clear Front Runners in the
Shadow race but it does seem as though
by accepting this debate DeSantis is is
accepting his second tier candidate
status and then putting all of his chips
on second tier okay yeah we're not
looking like we're going to dislodge
Trump anytime soon but I'm going to
cement my place as the clear and Away
number two Choice should something
happen to Trump now Newsome for his part
is apparently Furious from the DeSantis
accepted the the debate so he made all
these stipulations DeSantis agreed to
pretty much all of them and even on some
ridiculous ones you know DeSantis wants
to put the debate on or rather Newsom
wants to put the debate way way into the
future DeSantis wants it to be
relatively soon but he says okay I'll
accept the earliest date that Newsome
has to offer except basically the format
the moderator Newsome has all these
these stipulations that the sand is
trying to accommodate and then Newsome
comes back and he says what a joke this
according to a Newsome spokesman
DeSantis counter proposal is littered
with crutches to hide his insecurity and
ineptitude swapping opening statements
with a hype video cutting down the time
he needs to be on stage adding cheat
notes in a cheering section okay that's
pretty unfair DeSantis did propose a a
video statement for each candidate
rather than an opening statement so okay
maybe they cave on that uh cutting down
the time they need to be on stage well
okay they can set the time whether it's
an hour whether it's three hours you're
gonna get the point they're both going
to show up and then adding cheat notes
it's perfectly ordinary to have notes on
stage but okay maybe they lose that one
too in a cheering section well the
cheering section proposed by the
DeSantis campaign was that there'd be a
live audience and the the audience be
split 50 50. so it's not just that yeah
you're going to flood the audience with
the Santa supporters Newsome can get his
own supporters too the reason that
Newsome hates that is because DeSantis
has a clearly defined base within the
GOP that would prefer DeSantis over
Trump
obviously it's not the majority of the
GOP right now where DeSantis would be
the front runner but there there is a
strong core of DeSantis supporters at
least enough to fill an auditorium for
Newsom it's not quite the case because
Newsome is technically not running for
president yet and he's not being all
that aggressive against Biden so his
base a little unclear if he can really
tap into those kinds of people the other
thing here that's good news for DeSantis
is it shows Newsome thinks that DeSantis
will be relatively strong in a debate
so it was a big Bluff DeSantis comes out
of this looking really good if Newsom
will not debate although if the debate
does happen ironically I think it will
probably diminish DeSantis as a
candidate because it's going to show
that this guy's running for number two
now DeSantis doesn't want to run for
number two so he's getting more
aggressive against Trump according to a
report from The New York Times
while DeSantis was just addressing a
campaign event in Iowa he came out
finally and answered pretty clearly his
view of what happened in the 2020
election and his view is the election
was not stolen and DeSantis along with a
number of other GOP candidates have kind
of been dancing around this question
because they don't want to irritate the
base but they also don't want to give
Trump credit but they also don't want to
look like conspiracy theorists or
whatever so here's what desanta said he
said
that the theories that were put out
following the 2020 election
did not prove to be true
and he said it was not an election that
was conducted the way I think that we
want to but that's different than saying
Maduro stole votes or something like
that those theories you know proved to
be unsubstantiated
okay
what's that mean
it means he's saying the election wasn't
stolen it wasn't even all that rigged
he's saying well it wasn't conducted the
way we want it to be conducted
but that's that's pretty mild language
here he's not he's not even now saying
it was a rigged election against Trump
and the reason that he's coming out and
saying that is because if he says the
election was rigged against Trump or the
election was stolen
by the Democrats from Trump
then
it would seem that he should endorse
Trump and say yeah Trump actually won so
the chief argument against Trump's
nomination which is that he can't win
the election that argument goes away
maybe
they could say at least well he he won
if it were a fair and swear race but
they managed to steal it from him and I
won't let them steal it from me but when
you're talking about a candidate
DeSantis just like all the other
candidates that doesn't control the
elections in Pennsylvania in Arizona in
Georgia and Michigan
neither did Trump when he was president
so it it's kind of you can't really
blame him for that
then if you say well he really won
fairness where the argument for I I'm
much more electable than that guy is
goes out the window so he can't say that
but he also can't come out and say it
was complete BS Trump is full of it the
election was totally fine he lost fair
and square because if he does that he's
going to irritate a large part of the
Trump base and a lot of people are just
not going to believe it I don't know
people who really believe that election
was fair and square and yes I know
there's Shenanigans in every election
but
there are Shenanigans and there's
Shenanigans okay there's Shenanigans in
that sometimes the unions bust some
people out of District to vote more than
once and their Shenanigans like we're
going to completely remake the electoral
system to have widespread mail-in
ballots in all the places that really
count we're going to take days and weeks
to count the ballots and we're going to
violate the state constitution in some
cases and we're gonna have pipes burst
in the middle of the night that's a
that's a different level of shenanigans
okay so different that I think it's
probably different not only in degree
but in kind so what's he going to do
DeSantis is in this impossible spot I'm
not saying he's doing anything wrong or
unwise as a candidate it's just this was
always the problem built in for a strong
Republican Governor running against
Trump this time
the deck is just so politically stacked
against a challenger and part of the
reason that nobody wanted to hear when I
was saying it is that this is not like
an ordinary Open primary
Trump is running effectively as the
incumbent because it's the first time
since 1888 that we've seen a former
president run for non-consecutive second
term
and on top of that Republican voters
care deeply about election Integrity so
does Ron DeSantis that's why after the
2020 election Ron DeSantis changed all
those election rules to tighten it up
because he saw what the Democrats did in
2020. so DeSantis signed into law
widespread restrictions on absentee
ballots unmail and voting limitations on
the use of those ballot drop boxes which
were obviously Rife with fraud and he
increased the identity requirements so
you might say well that's good news that
means DeSantis knows how to run the
election yes it does but it also shows
that he knows just like the rest of the
GOP knows that the Democrats rigged the
thing in 2020 well if the Democrats
rigged the thing in 2020 then there's a
shot that Trump isn't quite so
unelectable as they're all saying which
seems to imply that people ought to
Rally around Trump so it's this
perfect knot there's really no move here
that and forget to send this that any of
the candidates can make against Trump
that is going to it's going to be a
clean victory
either way you're going to be irritating
some large part of the GOP base
and by the way all these prosecutions
now the big prosecutions that they're
talking about all stem directly or
indirectly from January 6th what
happened on January 6th we have a new
novel theory of January 6th from Al
Sharpton on MSNBC
one day our children's children will
read American history and can you
imagine our reading the James Madison or
Thomas Jefferson tried to overthrow the
government so they could stay in power
that's what we're looking at we're
looking at American history
can you imagine that
can you imagine if Thomas Jefferson
tried to overthrow the government
like if he did it by writing like a
declaration let's say where he declared
we're not going to recognize your
government anymore you know let's say
they had some other kind of guy they
didn't have a government that we have
now let's say they I don't let's say
they had like a king or something right
and he wrote and said we're I'm going to
overthrow your government I'm not going
to be dependent on you guys anymore I'm
going to declare myself to be
independent could you imagine that and
if they wrote up like a whole new
constitution let's say
for this new government and then like
imagine if Thomas Jefferson then became
a president in that new government after
they overthrew the old one could you
imagine
so weird
I love it when the libs accidentally
make our points for us
when they accidentally admit that their
arguments aren't as strong as they say
that they are this is not just a problem
though for the the Trump insurrectionist
Maga coup d'etat people and it's not
even just a problem for the BLM
insurrectionists who tried to overthrow
the government for eight months
this is a problem
for our understanding of American
history
because we're told it's absolutely the
word January 6 is the worst thing ever
because you're not ever allowed to rebel
against your government
because this is America a country that
was founded in a very famous probably
the most famous ever Rebellion against a
government
how do we make sense of that we'll get
we'll get to that one second when you
want to make sense of a whole lot of
questions in the country though you got
to check out prageru right now go to
prageru.com Club five our country might
be headed in the wrong direction but
prageru videos could help save the
future of America prageru makes
educational pro-american content that
has been changing people's minds for
over a decade their impact is pivotal in
these times our friends at Prager you
are reaching millions of people with
their educational videos they have a
long way to go you can help Prager you
reach thousands more people by joining
Club five for just five bucks or more
per month go to prageru.com Club five
now to join your gift will ensure that
prageru has the support it needs to be
here for the Long Haul what are you
waiting for join a movement with
thousands of fellow Patriots in the
fight to save America you'll receive a
free Prager U bumper sticker plus an
e-book of scripts from prageru's five
minute videos when you join Club 5 today
that is prageru.com Club five c l u b
number five today there's all sorts of
great content at prageru I've been in a
ton of five minute videos obviously I
host the book club over at prageru so
there's there's really great educational
content for everybody prageru.com Club
five today
the greatest interview show on the
internet yes or no is back with an all
new episode this time Candace Owens is
on the hot seat sipping drinks was
Princess Diana's death a little bit sus
have either of us cried in the past year
find out Candace's answers in our
episode check out this teaser
men who don't work out are like women
who cry on Tick Tock after their pet
bunny dies it's disordered weak and hard
to look at
just funny
[Music]
the yes or no game is now back in stock
finally you go to dailywire.com shop to
get your game today the games go very
fast they always sell out yes or no is
hands down the best way to delve into
the most thought provoking topics of our
time with family and friends go to
dailywire.com shop and order yes or no
today
could you imagine if Thomas Jefferson
overthrew the government yeah can't
imagine that so how do we make sense of
that how does the left make sense of its
Pearl clutching over January 6th when
our country was founded
on a major Revolution that took many
many lives because the colonists in
America felt that taxes were a little
too high
how do you make sense of that and vice
versa how do the conservatives get all
in a tizzy about BLM burning the country
for eight months when our country was
founded
in a violent revolution
not quite so violent and unreasonable as
the French Revolution but a revolution
nonetheless
it's a hard question it's a really hard
nut especially for conservatives
I think the solution here though is to
ground American patriotism
in a deeper context
for the last I don't know 20 30 40 years
in American politics we've had almost an
exclusive focus on the right on the
American founding era of the 1770s 1780s
1790s
that was considered to be the true
essence of America that hasn't always
been the way that we viewed ourselves in
this country
but that's what's happened in recent
decades
and I don't think we need to throw that
out a ton of Great Men in that founding
era wonderful events I've got two
ancestors of mine fought in that
Revolution John and Simon Knowles
fought a Battle of Bunker Hill John died
from his wounds of Bunker Hill Simon
went on to Valley Forge went on to White
Plains fought with Washington I like it
and we have Civic associations in
America like the sons of the American
Revolution sons of the revolution in New
York and other states that preserve that
and you can't have a country
that is in any way conservative if you
just totally diss your forebears but I
think that the way that we can do it is
by deepening that context and saying
well America didn't just begin at a thin
air in 1776 or 1775 it began its started
the American identity was forged in the
French and Indian War
which came 20 years before that the
American identity was formed much longer
actually it was about 140 years before
that 150 years before that at Plymouth
Rock with the Mayflower with the
pilgrims with the Puritan colonists in
Massachusetts with the the negotiations
and wars with the Indians with the
arrival of new settlers with the the
settling of the South with well and end
in the 19th century and in part of the
20th century I think you've got to
deepen that you go even further back
America didn't just pop out of thin air
as I know a lot of liberals want to say
there's a context that goes back to
the old country you know we were founded
as a Christian Nation where that
Christianity come from came from a
particular perspective of Christianity
that came out of the Puritans that lied
in who who had left England they were
non-conformists there where did that
tradition come from well it came out of
England
where did that tradition come from you
know Britain was a was a Roman territory
there's there are deeper Wellsprings
here
same same goes when we think about the
American people same goes when we think
about our geography and our place what
makes us unique a country is not just an
idea floating in at outer space a
country is not just some part piece of
parchment called the Declaration of
Independence or the Constitution those
documents are are terrific all well and
good I'm not dissing the documents at
all but a country's more than that a
country is flesh and blood and lived
traditions and beliefs and a connection
throughout the generations that that's
going to be the way that we get around
the Al Sharpton trap so that we don't
sound quite so incoherent as he does on
MSNBC now speaking of patriotism I am
thrilled that the U.S women's national
soccer team lost their match and are not
going to the next big match I guess it's
for the world cup is what comes next I'm
thrilled and I'm thrilled that the final
kick of the career of Megan rapino
one of the most odiously unpatriotic
anti-American athletes ever to wear an
American Jersey ended with her missing
the kick I'm thrilled about that and I'm
thrilled that she ended her career
whining on camera
yeah I thought we played really well
um I thought we played really well I'm
so happy for us that we went out like
that um can you put a pause there please
hold on before we we'll keep going for a
second but this is just such a
liberal
woman thing this is such a liberal white
lady thing where
she says oh I'm so proud of us we did so
well we were we're so good we're just so
we're the best ever
I'm so proud that we lost I'm so proud
that I totally blew it at the end
why why are you it's okay you don't need
to be beating yourself up over you don't
need to be flagellating yourself but you
lost lady don't be proud of that you
didn't play that well that's the problem
if you played better you would have won
the game and gone I think man
growing up in the 90s I'm watching the
New York Yankees
Paul O'Neill heart and soul of the New
York Yankees in the 90s this has got one
of the great baseball players of his era
Paul O'Neill if he would let's say you
know Fly ball to the Outfield and he
only got
One RBI instead of two RBIs there you
know and he he did and you know the guy
catches the ball whatever Paul O'Neill
would rip the telephone out of the
Dugout wall he would knock over the
Gatorade cooler he'd scream and yell and
throw his Bat on there he just he was so
Furious he took any loss or failure of
performance so personally and this lady
who completely blows it and loses it for
the team I'm so proud we're so great we
deserve 10 parades please give us
trophies and okay all right rant over
keep going Mrs rupino Ms rapino playing
the way that we did and you know having
a ton of Joy on the ball
um I mean this is like a sick joke for
me personally I'm just like this is dark
comedy I missed a penalty
um this is the the balance to the
beautiful side of the game I think it
can be cruel and
um just not our day but
yeah I I still just feel
really grateful and joyful and you know
I know it's the end and that's sad but
um
you know to know that this is really the
only time I've been in in one of these
um this early
um you know says so much about how much
how much success I've been able to have
and
um
just how much I've loved playing for
this team and playing for this country
and
yeah it's been an honor there we go then
she cracks I'm really proud we did great
I'm awesome I'm the greatest ever I'm so
but I blew it it's so dark why did I
blow it I know you did you did it's the
first step is
first step in grieving is is
acknowledging reality okay
why am I so happy that this lady lost
isn't that unpatriotic of me
because it's the U.S women's soccer team
isn't that unpatriotic
well it would be
except the team is very unpatriotic I
know that's a paradox but a paradox is
not just an incoherence or a
contradiction it's an apparent
contradiction that can reveal a deeper
truth when you work it out and and when
you work it out here you see
that
the team that is supposed to represent
the United States
consistently undermines the United
States protests the national anthem the
star spaniel Banner the symbol of the
whole country
is actively anti-patriotic
and so it is you cannot say that
patriotism requires us to applaud
the people who are deeply unpatriotic
you that would undermine it it reminds
me of a line from Chesterton
Chesterton said there is a thought that
stops thought
and that is the only thought that ought
to be stopped
there is there is a patriotism that
undermines patriotism and that kind of
pseudo-patriotism really ought to be
stopped as far as I'm concerned the U.S
women's soccer team could just be
abolished
cancel it I don't know maybe there are
some patriotic people on the team it's
too bad that the loudest mouth on the
team Megan rapino has so consistently
attacked our country but just abolish it
what is the point of the US Women's
Soccer Team it's not to kick a ball
around it's not to make Megan rapino
feel good it's to represent the United
States to bring glory to our country
that's the point of the team
so if they're if they're actively
undermining that then they have no
purpose and if the salt loses its Savor
then it's good for nothing and ought to
be trodden underfoot okay maybe now that
this lady is gone and can go off into
the sunset maybe the team will remember
what their job is and they can salute
the flag and stop being so deeply
unpatriotic but until then get rid of it
I mean this is a big big political
problem because you've got huge swaths
of America
and hate the country
and then hate traditional Notions of
patriotism and inasmuch as they love the
country they love the country because
they say the country stands for I don't
know
LGBT rights that's that's the deepest
meaning of America who people who really
believe that the rainbow flag is our
national standard or ought to be who
would be much more likely to salute the
rainbow flag than to salute the American
flag then you got the other more than
half of the country that still believes
in the red white and blue and doesn't
believe in all the craziness that
Rapinoe and the libs do but that's a big
problem because if you don't have
shared
beliefs if you don't have shared
sacred objects if you don't have shared
language if you don't have shared
Behavior if you don't have any shared
culture then you don't have a country
doesn't matter which
team is representing your country you
don't have one to be represented in the
first place so on this point of
patriotism I've had this question in
recent days which is
why some people on the right
have exalted
a
British pimp why parts of the Christian
conservative American right have exalted
a British Muslim
pimp who seduced women and played with
their emotions to turn them into
prostitutes so that he could steal most
of the money
how that became I'm talking of course of
Andrew Tate and so my friend zubi
tweets out what got me thinking about
this my friend zubi tweets out
Andrew Tate has positively impacted the
lives of millions of young men
objectively if you can do better than do
better I'm doing my best with my
platform talents and influence the pro
clutching and finger wagging is tedious
and disingenuous
I guess my question to zooby's
declaration here is
has he
has Andrew Tate positively impacted the
lives of millions of young men
how
is he told them to you know go out and
make some money or something go work
hard I
they say that Andrew Tate has moved on I
don't know much about Andrew Tate's
biography they say oh no it was years
ago 10 years ago he was a pimp but now
he doesn't now from what I've seen the
evidence is he's been pimping until
pretty recently they say well the
charges in Romania have nothing to do
with him being a big pimp and seducing
these women and selling their flesh and
I said well I don't know it looks to me
like the charges have quite a lot to do
with that uh but let's say let's say
even he was doing this until a few years
ago two years ago I don't know whenever
it was but then he he converted he said
I'm I'm done with this I Repent this was
wrong okay well then maybe like chill
for a little while you know if you've
been doing something that is egregiously
evil and scandalous and very destructive
to people not just people's bodies but
souls for years and years and years and
you've enriched yourself on that then
maybe you ought to take a moment
process your supposedly major change of
heart maybe make some reparation try to
make some reparation with some of those
ill-gotten gains and then maybe come
back in a few years and explain
you know how you've seen the light
I haven't seen Andrew Tate do any of
that
so what does zubi mean I don't know I
admittedly I don't know Andrew Tate I
don't think he's the worst guy in the
world but
he's a degenerative for everything I've
seen about this guy is that he's a total
degenerate and if he's repented great
but I haven't
you gotta like take a pause there man
so what is what is it that he's done
obviously zuby's not saying it's good
that he's a big pimp that that's helped
with men's lives so what is it and then
it got I I think it got to the point
that I understood which is
Andrew Tate is an internet self-help
Guru
and he's not just one who dispenses good
advice for free he charges people or has
charged people to be part of his fake
kind of Academy he says give me a bunch
of money and I'll teach you how to be a
big player and you know I'll teach you
how to be really rich and powerful and
pick up women and all this stuff
so he's
at best I think an internet self-help
Guru scam artist
which is not much better than being a
pimp and as a public matter it's
probably worse this is the and it's not
just Andrew tape I know I'm beating up
on Andrew Tate here there are so many of
these guys and so many of these online
Guru scammy artist type people
are either useless they might sincerely
believe they're helping but they're not
or they're frauds they're just deceiving
people to get money to pretend they're
selling but it's this stuff is always
snake oil and the reason it's always
snake oil is there is there is one way
to improve yourself
and the way to improve yourself
and there's a natural component and a
supernatural component the natural
component is to practice virtues and to
stop practicing Vice and the
supernatural component is to accept the
grace of God and your lord and savior
who took on flesh and dwelt Among Us
that's it that's the the only self-help
book you will ever need is the Bible
and
the books that have come out of the
Bible
and the religious tradition that
compiled the Bible and Remains the bride
of Christ the Living God that that's it
that's the self-help and all these other
guys who try to do it who try to divorce
God from goodness who try to divorce
religion and morality from
self-improvement they're always going to
leave you high and dry this is why it is
the I mean my my most miserable friends
in New York and LA are the ones who have
read the most self-help books
I just don't see it man how does that
positively impact the lives of millions
of people
huh
that's kind of weird
now are you planning to send your kid
off to college this year
listen
I've been on many campuses I've seen
firsthand how woke ideology has
infiltrated and polluted these once
great universities give your kids a
Fighting Chance by sending them off with
Jeremy's razors right now get up to 20
off select razor and men's care bundles
like the shampoo body wash and
conditioner all paraben free sulfate
free woke free and made in the USA and
get them a Precision 5 razor with welded
steel blades and a flip back trimmer
that will groom his face not his world
view
help your son Escape academia's leftist
indoctrination by more than just a close
shave go to jeremy'srazors.com for major
deals and give Jeremy's back to college
bundles a full ride today
my favorite comment on Fridays from
Skyhawk 4526 who says I'm trying to
figure out which is more absurd Mia
Khalifa Trying to give women marriage
advice or Anthony blink in lecturing the
world about the wrongfulness of
political prisoners great Point you're
referring of course to the world's two
oldest professions
which Ronald Reagan pointed out bear a
striking similarity to the two of them
politics and
prostitution I don't know I don't know
if I had to spell it out for you you
know sometimes it's confusing to figure
out which is which
speaking of weird sex stuff
former Democrat mayor was just caught
with child pornography this is Patrick
wojon he's the Democrat ex-mayor of
College Park Maryland he pled guilty to
140 counts of child porn possession and
distribution in a deal that stipulates
the former politicians serve
three decades in prison
uh I could very easily make jokes about
the Democrats all being pedos and how I
could point out that maybe this this is
more pronounced on the left and I
suspect it is but
I don't want to be a hack okay so I'm
going to observe yeah sometimes
right-wingers get caught in weird sex
stuff including in this which is about
as egregious as it could possibly be
child pornography child exploitation and
it's not just the atheists sometimes
it's religious people and it's not just
the politicians sometimes it's I don't
know people Threat all of society okay
it's
very pervasive my main takeaway from
this issue is I strongly suspect that
this
problem is much more widespread than
people want to admit
and I had that hunch so I just Googled
it I said what is the prevalence of
child pornography
one of the first results that come up is
from a group called the demand project
here's what it says child porn is one of
the fastest growing crimes in the U.S
nationally there's a 2500 percent
increase in arrests in the past 10 years
that's according to the FBI the national
Center for missing and exploited
children reviewed 17.3 million images
and videos of child porn in 2011 that is
four times more it's an insane number
but for our purposes what matters is
it's four times more than they reviewed
in 2007. so in the span of four years
you get four times more child born
uh what psychologists have learned
apparently is that when someone becomes
addicted to child pornography they
progress
to younger and younger children and more
sadistic and extreme cases of of this
stuff which of course makes sense
because that's how all pornography works
because that's how all addiction works
because it's you start out with a little
puff on the devil's lettuce and pretty
soon you're smoking you know the uh the
hunter rocks out of a glass tube on Skid
Row
is that you you either
break addictions and bad habits or they
get more and more extreme 2006 this is
all according to the demand project
I assume there are many other sources on
this it's literally the first thing I
clicked on 2006 U.S attorneys handled
82.8 percent more child porn cases than
they had in 1994 huge increase obviously
an estimated 50 000 50 000 people in the
United States are believed to quote be
consistently trading illegal images
involving children at any one time at
any one time 50 000 people consistently
dealing in this stuff
and furthermore 63 of teens said they
know how to hide what they do online
from their parents so a lot more those
are just the bullet points that jumped
out at me which tells me
yes this guy this Democrat mayor of
College Park man I he is God into some
dark stuff and it doesn't exonerate him
in any way and um but I don't want to
especially knock him because this is
also obviously a political problem it's
not just the cultural well we've got to
Route the bad guys out there's obviously
a political problem here how do you
explain those numbers increasing
we've talked about this with other
ideologies that we're not allowed to
mention on big Tech certain identity
ideologies that have exploded in recent
years
three times the rate of identification
with certain sexual ideologies in in
recent years you say okay well that
can't just be an individual problem
that can't unlike it can't even just be
an environmental problem unless there's
something in the water turning the
freaking frogs gay that's obviously got
to be a pervasive cultural and political
problem
it's a technological problem
why did the numbers Spike from the 90s
to the 2000s do you think it has
something to do with the internet coming
around yeah obviously
how could you fix this then
you could shame these people yeah good
you could
I don't know I don't know how you shame
them more it's already the most shameful
thing you could possibly imagine I think
you need to regulate this stuff
and you say well the child pornography
is already regulated yeah but the
internet largely isn't and pornography
generally isn't at all
it's not regulated at all the American
people have tried to regulate it on
multiple occasions Republicans and
Democrats child online protection act
and the communications decency act in
the 90s and early 2000s passed with
majorities and signed into law by
Democrat president
then liberal judges shoot it down so now
you've got to the point where the the
porn stuff is basically unregulated
well if you if you only focus on this
most egregious horrific version of porn
you're probably not going to catch it
numbers are going to keep growing if you
however
cut off the main supply of people who
get into the funnel where eventually I
guess it could lead to this stuff
I think you're gonna have much more
success
and what's going to be required there is
a less liberal view of
porn and
speech even I don't think obscenity is
speech but you're not you're gonna have
to have a more illiberal view and say no
you're just not allowed to look at this
stuff and it's going to choke off the
industry and big porn is terrified of
this this is why big porn just we'll get
to the story Tomorrow there's gonna be
my little tease for tomorrow big porn uh
PornHub and its parent company mindgeek
just cut off Arkansas this is just the
latest state to be cut off from this
porn website because Arkansas insists on
verifying people's ages and big porn is
so afraid of age verification that they
would rather shut off their service in
that state than comply with the law
what does that tell you it tells you
they're trying to hook people when
they're very young just like any drug
Peddler on the street and they know that
children that minors are very important
to the way the whole business operates
so you're not gonna you're not gonna
this is my somewhat Vindication of
Andrew Tate or not really I'm just
trying to be a little softer on them
you're not going to stop this problem by
just going after the random mayor in
College Park Maryland you're not going
to stop this problem by getting some
low-level webcam Pimp Like Andrew Tate
you're going to stop this problem by
arresting and imprisoning the CEO of
mindgeek the owners of the the biggest
porn companies in the world and shutting
off the service that's how you're going
to get serious about it as long as we
don't do that as long as we pretend
there's some Civil Right to look at smut
or something
the problem is only going to get worse
and those numbers are going to continue
to explode by multiples and Orders of
magnitude now today my friends it's
music Monday rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles kwles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
all right